welcome back st jude's ranch for
children will hold their
there's no place like hope an in-person
micro gala and virtual events
on saturday may 1st here to tell us all
about this event is christina vela the
ceo for st jews ranch for children
welcome christina now
we're very excited about this event tell
us who's going to benefit
yeah we're really excited to host an
in-person event of course to benefit st
jude's ranch for children
but it's for one of our newest projects
for the healing center which will be to
care for
child victims of sex trafficking now
you're actually at the venue it's taking
place at the venetian walk us through
the night an in-person event this is
huge walk us through the evening
yeah you know so we've taken a lot of
precautions to make it really super
covert conscious so we have two micro
events one starts at 5 pm
and is being hosted by jennifer lear and
we're honoring amy a u but community
hero
and then the 6 p.m is is being hosted by
clint holmes
and we are honoring those vaqueros as
community heroes as well
and so we've you know it's just going to
be so much fun it's wizard of oz
inspired
and we can't wait to see everybody in
the room now there's going to be
entertainment as well
and a silent auction and before we went
on the air you told me you had some
breaking news
regarding a donation you want to share
that with us what do you what's going on
yeah so you know as i mentioned this is
to support the healing center this will
be the first
project in southern nevada to care for
child victims of sex trafficking
and we are so excited to announce that
because of an incredibly generous donor
we have just received a one million
dollar commitment
what one million dollars wow a million
dollars
i know from an incredible student right
wow
everyone here in the studio is
applauding that's amazing
that's so amazing we are so incredibly
grateful
yeah i'm kind of speechless actually i
don't know what to say
so i know it's an in-person event as
well but people can watch virtually
where do they go to get ticket
information how do they watch virtually
yep so everything is on our website at
studentsranch.org
right when you land on the page it'll
say attend our gala you can come to the
either one of the two in-persons or the
virtual event
we are so excited to celebrate our
accomplishments with the community
and to share more about the exciting and
really necessary healing center
project christina thank you so much
we're looking forward to the event
happening may 1st congratulations on
that
million donation it's a great way to
start the weekend
rocky we'll send it over to you wow that
is amazing another i know